[Music]
how much money you guessing dr jay's
worth oh he's a billionaire now right
yeah billiard oh was that fake
that's got to be true i heard he's back
under a beat because his wife took it
because i know how much he's paying his
wife every month how much
i heard the number was 300k a month 300
damage but she was but she was asking
for like
600k or something like something crazy
and then i guess they just talked it
down to
300k i don't even think it's child
support
it's like something else no it was like
alimony right i think it's alimony
three million a year then that's damn
good for her so yeah i think he's under
a bill now he's he's down at 800 mil oh
man
lost another one it's kind of hurt the
ego y'all know how it is
so yeah um but his daughter is basically
living out of her car i heard about that
i was like [ __ ] what kind of uh uh
shitty
person do you have to be
where your parents won't pay for you
anymore dude he helps eminem more than
her bro is she like 37 though no she's
she's not she's she's like six
she's 38. she's 38 for real living out
of a rolls-royce it's funny here to
think that she's six years old and she
just lives out of a car and she's really
sick living out of a bentley that's
pretty good yeah she does have a nice
car though because she's basically
saying yo like my dad i haven't really
seen him in 20 years
and every time that i communicate with
him it's through his people and then she
says that
um maybe he's tired of her [ __ ] he
stopped giving her money like 18 months
ago
she's [ __ ] 38. oh 38 really 38 no no
that's how old she is dude
why she need to be raised
she says that um her car is an suv that
costs twenty three hundred dollars for
three weeks
and um
sooner or later they're gonna take that
why does suv cost two thousand three
hundred for three weeks
like a lamborghini or something kind of
weird deals you get lamborghini it
sounds like it's a rental car it just
sounded like some spoiled rich kid [ __ ]
and they don't know how to like earn for
themselves yeah and then they they're
putting out the store like i have to
live in the car and it's like well
you're 38
you shouldn't be asking for money from
parents i only get 10 g's a month for
rent how do i live like that no [ __ ]
dude 2 300 every three weeks for your
car how the [ __ ] what does that mean
what does three weeks mean like that's
blowing it's not even a full month yeah
what is she doing going to [ __ ] rent
a car from the mafia yeah dude seriously
yeah dude different building cycles
how the [ __ ] did she set that up
what was it like a special edition land
like land rover like the [ __ ] over at
the dealership transformer edition
does she have the new the new
lamborghini suv isn't even that much
yeah it's like what 50 000 or something
50 no way the oh wait never mind it's
gotta be like six figures still entered
a raffle for it
so i think it was like you i think you
get the car plus fifty thousand dollars
yeah it was amazing what do you think is
the right age to cut off your kids from
paying them anything dog like 38 is
pushing it bro
i say like an allowance for a 38 year
old that sounds ridiculous i think bro
if you hit 27
that's it that's the cut off
why have you been generous if you're
being 20s not mid 20s [ __ ] like 18.
yeah what's your range i just got a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's 27. i'm just saying if
you're dr dre's kid let's think about
this right okay if you're dr dre's kid
there's no way you're going to be that
cool
right because thinking about how good of
a life you had who's the parents miss
kids
are they cool though but they're [ __ ]
they're like they're cool for hollywood
teammates moguls but if you're a normal
person you're sitting down talking oh
that's different that's different yeah
like jayden's [ __ ] i don't like i
don't know 12 year old billionaire yeah
that's different that's different is he
really he's a billionaire i don't know
some [ __ ] like what age or can you stay
on your parents health insurance 25 40.
that's the max i would say 25. i say two
years more if you're a doctor
yeah can you just not even give them
anything what happens there
at what it feels like you're like
fighting like parental advice or a kid
we don't know about sad stories about
you because in the back back in the day
right you stopped joe's getting free
legal advice from us yeah so if you have
a like a kid that
[Laughter]
like back in the day where people had
kids because the kids [ __ ] worked for
them they brought value now the kids
drain from them yeah you had a farm you
pump out 10 of them now you got [ __ ]
five
people going out picking your beats yeah
you got some new employees
that's because of cooks like these guys
saying you're out at 31.
36 is enough bro 136 that's it like you
cut off good lord
never having 18. yeah no i just mean as
far as like being a celebrity kid right
like those kids are gonna people too man
they're gonna have problems dog like if
you don't treat you any different you're
a brown belt in brazilian jiu jitsu
but that was burned fool it wasn't given
to him
i wanted you to say that i got that on
my knees for that you know what i mean
wink wink but we're going back to kids
we're going back to if you're a kid of a
celebrity
i think it's it's so much harder for you
to be well adjusted to the world if you
grow up with like dr dre being your dad
isn't that it's called uh not influenza
[ __ ] that's just
called
you guys heard of that [ __ ] yeah
affluenza affluenza yeah have you heard
affluenza
sounds like a pharmaceutical
that's a new vaccine bro so what you're
saying is
these rich kids they don't even grow up
in a normal world right so they have a
different view of reality and then they
do these stupid ass things right bro you
see tom hanks's son so so the point is
calling chet hanks crazy so the point is
if you commit a crime as a [ __ ] rich
kid or whatever they argue in court that
this kid has affluenza
yeah see that's because there's rich
kids that sounds like dude rich people
made them dui
and they kill people and then they try
to get away clean like oh your honor
they have affluenza that's the rich
version of like oh he's mentally
unstable yeah you're a senator's son or
some [ __ ] yeah claiming in
insanity that's [ __ ] affluenza you
guys are generalizing too much i
disagree with all of this is universal
sign language for [ __ ]
that's tight that's a dance move oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know sosa bacon kevin bacon's
daughter she what's her name so see
bacon sosie she's on that whatever a
show
okay she her dad kevin bacon and his
wife kira sedgwick they basically cut
her off early on so basically she's like
every actor in la she just lives like in
a whatever like a 700 red apartment good
hair is good but she missed her parents
on the weekend under manchester she's
just one degree away from kevin megan
i didn't like that
you're trying to be a hollywood name
dropping ass [ __ ]
you could have said it you could have
said it i didn't like it but say it
again but add a little bit of difference
put some cheese on it yeah put some
cheese on it's a good timeline oh that's
good
oh yeah that's when he pops out the
curtain put some cheese on it if you
ever have a problem with your food just
put some cheese on it
put some cheese on that [ __ ]
there's a guy in the crowd he's ready to
put some cheese on his shirt he's going
crazy bro
he's in the front row just going bro
he's like oh my god he's here
he shows up with cheese on his face yes
it's got all the tour dates on the back
cheese whiz
did you guys get allowance growing up or
no when i got into high school my mom
would give me like five bucks a day for
lunch for like uh monday through friday
is that allowance
that's lunch money bro pizza dude you're
getting the pizzas get like i was able
to get like chick-fil-a or a hot pocket
or whatever yeah chick-fil-a at school
that's that's good like just a sandwich
like a chicken sandwich or you could get
like patties uh or like a pizza hut uh
the sticks oh yeah the breadsticks are
bothered 2.50 cents with the marinara
sauce you know what
isn't it weird at the school they always
had the branded [ __ ] but you can't get
that at the store like i remember
remember we had subway but i swear to
god it was just a rapper of the subway
rapper but the the sandwich is not even
subway it's like 7-eleven so what's up
yeah they had dominoes like the or the
pizza hut like personal but when you
open it it's like is this really [ __ ]
pizza yeah it was pretty good oh good i
still hate it all the time you got
little caesars too i was like this is
that's what damn little caesars
that was the standard right that was
yeah it was like this is twenty dollars
make it last make it work yeah you got
five bucks today like 25 bucks and then
instead of like using it to buy food at
school you would just like save it so
that you can buy stupider things and you
just freeload off like random ponies
right
let me get a fry let me get a hot cheeto
let me get a bite of that yup yup that's
how you make it what do you say that
money for drugs video games pokemon
cards fossils
you were just an investor back then you
didn't even know yet yeah you still got
your pokemon cards yeah i just don't
know where they are because my arms are
hoarders i found a bunch of old pokemon
you do i
don't know what to do with them what do
i do with my pokemon look up the values
of them no dude they're worthless let me
have them though
okay i have a whole binder full
are they mint conditions bro you might
be
in hundreds of thousands of dollars
right now you don't even know yeah don't
man don't get them appraised
dude leave here right now and go crazy
pokemon cards aren't cool but let me
just have them who do i go talk to
together i don't know dude you're brown
brazilian jiu jitsu
creepy it's so weird bro
look at it
before you bring it here okay anthony
will go praise it for you just beat the
shot at me see don't expect much though
it's not in right now yeah they're out
kind of yeah big time out yeah just give
it to me i'll take the burden off of you
i got some baseball cards in there too
this guy's pretty stupid huh
and i you know you know what's actually
really funny random as [ __ ] out of that
binder i have a bunch of like bruce lee
trading cards what
did it worth
bruce lee trading card
bro i don't know where i got him from i
don't know how was he on wait until you
the hologram jackie
dude i want to see what a bruce i'll
bring him and i got a kareem
abdul-jabbar one too yeah you swear game
of death from game of death bro your
your dad basically just printed out
pictures kind of out he just came to
keep like oh i bought you these cars
existed
it's not even a real card stock he
brings all his cards you keep the bruce
lee cards give me the pokemon
i thought you were a fan
you have holographics i don't know do
you know what they are yeah the the
shiny ones the shiny right the shiny
ones i had every one of them dude i had
every single one of them bryce toys my
dumb-ass treats don't have them though
you don't have them anymore no my mom's
at work there might be a hundred years
in your mom's garage
let's go over there dude let's find it
what if if your parents sold everything
in that house they could have lived so
much better but they don't i know dude
they could probably sell my i had a
first edition venusaur i remember that
wow that's good i paid 10 bucks for it
and change and the guy was so [ __ ]
pissed
[Music]